[Applaudissements]
si je vous disais que normalement
c'était perdu d'avancé
basic n'auront un drap c'est pas mal
pour un mec de province
si je vous disais que pour un mec un peu
paumé c'était impossible de remplir les
plus grandes salles de france de faire
des centaines de millions de vues avec
moi j'y ai cru dès le début
[Musique]
si je vous disais que j'ai tout filmé et
que personne n'a jamais vu les images
d
orelsan c'est mon grand frère et j'ai
toujours été persuadé que lui et ses
potes étaient destinés à faire de
grandes choses
pour l'écriture sur l'album c'est le
seul à qui j'ai pensé vous voyez un
artiste poser un truc cool mais très
différents
le premier souvenir est pas un très bon
souvenir en fait
c'était pas le jeu d'enfant de percer
dans la
vie tu arrêtais cote auprès du tout
comme cela mais basique au début on le
fait coûtèrent des gens autour de nous
ici de catastrophes faut pas sortir ça
ne sert à rien d'avoir peur parce que
c'est pas bien recommencer au moins ça
fait avancer et un ping
dans les suivants je voulais trouver le
secret pour réaliser ses rêves
vingt ans plus tard je suis prêt à le
partager
qui
et tant pis si lui désobéit course de
près 28 mai montre jamais ça à personne